[Music]
rarely do nature and architecture come
together so perfectly as a divine Greek
monasteries of meteora meteor is a
collection of Greek Orthodox monasteries
perched on rock pillars 1,300 feet above
ground they are built by Greek monks
from the 14th and 16th centuries they
were constructed by using a network of
ropes pulleys baskets and ladders which
lifted supplies up the dramatic cliffs
in a vision to solitude the location
brought the monks and locals a place of
protection from unwanted trespassers and
a sanctuary during invasions from the
Turks today only six of the original 20
monasteries remains but they are still
inhabited by 20 monks and four nuns who
are full-time residents the meteora is
one of only a handful of places that are
listed as a unesco world heritage site
under two categories nature and art
without changing the landscape the monks
managed to build monasteries that seemed
like extensions of the mountain itself
the day meteoric translates to suspended
in space these monasteries truly seem to
defy gravity
[Music]
you
[Music]